don't have a steam deck yet no worries
valve might give you one for free on
December 8th during the game awards the
maker of the steam deck valve will be
giving away the most expensive version
of the steam Deck with 512 gigabytes
every minute to viewers of the live
stream event if you want to be one of
those lucky viewers all you need to do
is head to the link we've attached in
the description sign into steam and then
hit register now then on December 8th
you must watch the game awards live
stream via steam yes steam does live
streaming if you didn't know to be in
with a chance of winning one considering
that last year the length of the game
awards rivaled the run time of one of
the Lord of the Rings movies valve is
set to give away hundreds of devices and
even if you have a steam deck already
you should register anyway because a who
doesn't need a second steam deck and B
everyone who read says it gets a very
cute steam pal digital sticker of course
you'll be wanting to pick up a steam
deck to replace your switch because the
technical issues of Pokemon scarlet and
violet have pushed you to the brink but
don't retire that nearly six-year-old
handheld just yet because in an
extremely rare acknowledgment by
Nintendo it seems that the game might
actually be getting some fixes the game
just got its first patch since launch
and will make some additions as well as
address some issues ranked battling is
coming to the game's battle stadium and
there have been some bug fixes including
a bug where the music during the game's
Elite 4 confrontations wouldn't play
correctly as for what the additional bug
fixes are who knows what exactly has
been mended in this patch but some of
the biggest ones include massive frame
rate drops pop in at extremely close
distances invisible legendaries and
clipping through environments to name a
few but it sounds like some if not all
of these problems will be addressed in
addition to the patch notes Nintendo
stated that quote we are aware that
players May encounter issues that affect
the game's performance our goal is to
always give players a positive
experience with our games and we
apologize for the inconvenience we take
the feedback from players seriously and
are working on improvements to the games
a statement like this is almost unheard
of from the gaming giant considering its
Rarity as well as the fact that scarlet
and violet have been Nintendo's fastest
selling games ever the breadth of the
issues as well as the volume of players
pointing them out must be immense
speaking of immense the biggest Lego
game of all time Star Wars the Skywalker
Saga will be coming to Xbox game pass on
December 6th the sprawling game allows
players to Journey back through all nine
episodes of The Saga starting at the
beginning of any trilogy they want
whether that to be The Phantom Menace A
New Hope or the force awakens with more
than 300 unlockable characters from all
my movies since its release in April the
game has also added some additional
content to the experience predominantly
to tie into the new Star Wars content
that has been released this year
including character packs for the
Obi-Wan Kenobi and Andor TV shows are
you going to be trying to win a free
steam deck from valve are you hopeful
that Nintendo is actually going to fix
the issues with Pokemon scars and violet
let us know in the comments we'll see
you here for more Gamespot news
foreign
[Music]